if you were to look at China and India
and those two countries specifically um
and you were to handicap them as you are
uniquely qualified to do maybe you could
just broadly handicap India versus China
for us because this is a topic we've
been talking about jamath and I and and
the other besties on the show a whole
bunch and it's now the largest
population in the world I guess people
don't realize that that they've uh and
they're continuing to grow and the birth
rate is in decline in China so maybe a
little bit on India and how you look at
it and I should emphasize that every
every conclusion that I have is a
function of of measuring statistics and
having them as leading indicators and we
have 10-year growth rate estimates for
uh China uh excuse me India um all the
countries top 22 countries and you could
see it online if you want country by
country and the reasons for it India has
the highest potential growth rate I
think India um is where China was when I
started to go I started to go in
1984 so if you look at the complexion
the per cap income and I think um Modi
is a d shell ping so that you have a um
a ma massive uh reform development
creativity all those elements there are
of course issues risk issues uh but
India is is very uh very important and I
don't think that any of these issues is
going to stop India I also in hist
history the countries that were the
neutral countries did the best so in
other words better than the winners in
Wars so as we have this conflict between
the United States and China and its
allies Russia and so on as we see that
lineup countries that are in the middle
like India are going to be net
beneficiaries Middle East Middle East is
again there's so there are two big
epicenters where things are happening
fast and quick um and getting better one
of them is um well let let's say three
there's the acon countries and we can
say that Singapore and essentially is a
hub but the acon countries which is you
know Indonesia Philippines Vietnam and
all of that that's going to be a good
great area the Middle East in terms of
particularly the gulf countries the
amount of money and they're and they're
making Talent magnets they're attracting
people that's you look at how the change
in is take place um that's certainly it
and India